da sie deine maske an du brauchst doch
eine
corona ist sehr gefährlich
jederzeit eine maske zur verfügung zu
haben das war in ihrem ersten leben
nicht selbstverständlich als jener noch
in nordkorea lebte heute lebt die mutter
von zwei kindern mit ihrer familien
südkorea und erinnert sich an die
entbehrungen
sie tragen in nordkorea entweder jeden
tag dieselbe maske oder waschen sie und
verwenden sie dann wieder das ist
unhygienisch
aber ich kann meinen verwalten keine
masken schicken
die 35 jährige joana ist vor drei jahren
aus nordkorea geflohen sie ließ ein
leben und ihre verwandten zurück um ihre
eigene familie zu retten
eines ihrer kinder hatte einen unfall
und brauchte dringend ärztliche
betreuung aber die gab es nicht
nordkorea schottet sich komplett ab
rihanna gibt einen seltenen einblick in
die dramatische lage des landes
es gibt nichts was die menschen tun
können die medizinische versorgung ist
miserabel es gibt kaum medikamente das
ist die realität in nordkorea krankheit
führt zum tod wenn
sie die nordkoreanische propaganda
bilder im staatsfernsehen sieht
schüttelt sie den kopf der diktator kim
jong un besucht eine apotheke in der
hauptstadt inszeniert sich als
krisenmanager
angeblich habe nordkorea erst kein
corona gehabt dann einen ausbruch mit
millionen infizierten und dutzenden
toten und jetzt habe man alles wieder im
griff
rihanna glaubt der regierung kein wort
das was die welt aus nordkorea zu sehen
bekommt hat mit der realität nichts zu
tun
kaum einer kennt so gut den zustand
nordkoreanischer krankenhäuser wie ich
ich selbst ein jahr hilfe für meinen
sohn dort gesucht habe wenn du krank
bist musst du dich selbst versorgen
apotheken gibt es so gut wie keine ich
bin von tür zu tür gelaufen und habe
versucht medikamente von anderen
familien zu kaufen
dr weiß wovon er spricht auch er ist
nordkoreaner und war einer der wenigen
gut ausgebildeten ärzte er arbeitete in
einem vorzeige krankenhaus in der
hauptstadt pjöngjang und beschäftigte
sich mit solchen vor wenigen jahren floh
er weil er die unterdrückung und die
armut nicht mehr aushielt seitdem
arbeitet er für die organisation freedom
speakers insel die den nordkoreanischen
flüchtlingen eine stimme gibt und über
die lage seiner ehemaligen heimat
aufklären werden
wir haben die patienten behandelt aber
der dank galt immer kim jong un ärzte
verdienen körpers mit unserem gehalt ist
es schwer in nordkorea ein kilogramm
reis zu kaufen
schon im februar berichtete ein
bekannter von drk aus nordkorea von
vielen kranken mit fieber und husten
solche nachrichten lassen schlimmes
befürchten
das land ist nicht auf corona
vorbereitet die bevölkerung nicht
geimpft millionen menschen dazu noch
unterernährt das einzige was der
politischen führung ein feld sind
lockdown
im nordkoreanischen fernsehen sprechen
sie immer nur vom fieber und geben
absurde behandlungs tipps
schlafen sie genug trinken sie genug
essen sie leicht verdauliches und spüren
sie den mund mit salzwasser aus
ratschläge die die ganze hilflosigkeit
des isolierten regimes zeigen
fast zwei jahre und drei monate haben
nordkoreas machthaber das land brutal
abgeriegelt die grenze dicht gemacht den
menschen geht es schlechter als je zuvor
kim jong-un regiert ein bitterarmes land
der korona ausbruch trifft auf einen
nordkorea dessen wirtschaft am boden
liegt grund sind auch die sanktionen
wegen des atomwaffenprogramms
kim hat nun im staatsfernsehen das
schlechte krisenmanagement
seiner beamten kritisiert
es darum die kritik von seiner person
fern zu halten
bestimmte institutionen oder deren
repräsentanten die kritisiert werden und
eben nicht die innere führungsriege ist
es nicht die kim familie
die hier für verfehlungen verantwortlich
gemacht wird
johanna spricht nicht so gerne über ihre
flucht sie ist nur froh dass sie kim
jong-un tyrannei entkommen konnte
dennoch vermisst sie manchmal ihre alte
heimat dann fährt sie an die grenze nur
wenige hundert meter entfernt und doch
existiert rüben eine andere welt eine
welt in der ein hoch ansteckendes virus
nur als fieber bezeichnet wird und ein
herrscher komplett das denken seines
volkes bestimmt
ich meine die menschen in nordkorea
haben keine möglichkeit die wahrheit zu
erfahren es gibt kein internet keine
unabhängigen informationen
seit unserer kindheit sagt uns der staat
was wir glauben sollen also haben wir
geglaubt was sie uns erzählt haben
manchmal dachte ich sie belügen uns aber
wenn sie es immer wiederholen dann
fängst du an alles zu glauben
am ende ihrer reise will georgia noch
eine schleife aufhängen sie hat nur
einen wunsch dass ihre verwandten corona
überleben und sie hat einen traum dass
sie sie irgendwann wieder sieht
[Musik]